hey guys I'm Abbey shark welcome to
Abby's kitchen there's a new Netflix
documentary in town and this one is
looking at some very controversial keto
diet so goodbye what the hell goodbye
and hello the magic pills so if you guys
haven't seen it yet this documentary is
all about how the low-carb high-fat diet
can supposedly cure a wide range of
illnesses so the documentary features
aloud testimonials and claims about how
the keto diet can supposedly cure things
like neurological diseases and chronic
diseases like cancer and diabetes and of
course promotes weight loss so in
today's video I'm gonna take a look at
the documentary and all the recent
literature around it and talk a little
about some of the things that I think
the magic pill actually got kind of
right to various degrees and then next
week you're gonna have to come back to
see what I think the magic pills got
very tragically wrong so let's do this
claim number one the keto diet can cure
childhood epilepsy let's take a look at
Abigail she's nonverbal she has epilepsy
central sleep apnea ok so Abigail
obviously has epilepsy and 40 minutes
into the documentary we learned that
Abigail's being on the keto diet for
about five weeks she's calmer her speech
is improved her bowel movements have
improved her seizures have decreased all
of the things that of course we want to
see ok so what does the research say
well cool fact the keto diet has
actually been used for the treatment of
childhood epilepsy for about 80 years
already a systematic review did find
that the keto diet can help to reduce
seizures in children with epilepsy
however this isn't the case for all
children and we of course we need a lot
more research here on the long-term
risks and how long children would need
to be on this so if your child does have
epilepsy and you want to try the keto
diet for them you definitely want to
make sure that they're being followed by
their position to make sure that they do
it properly claim number two the keto
diet can help treat autism let's meet
our friend Aaron
we knew from the moment he was put in
our arms at two weeks old we knew
something was amiss when he was three I
decided to put him on a specific
carbohydrate diet just meat vegetable
fruit nuts and seeds third day on
specific carbohydrate diet he fed
himself for the first time the fifth day
he said his first word so Aaron is
obviously on the autism spectrum and
after six months of being on the
ketogenic diet
apparently he's able to express himself
and useful sentences so the research
actually does support this in some ways
a recent somatic review did find that
the ketogenic diet may actually be
beneficial for patients with autism
however we definitely need a lot more
research and this is another scenario
that you would definitely want to be
monitored by a physician if you're
taking it on especially for children
claim three research flaws in low-fat
diets lately fat has been a really
controversial topic one day it's good
one day it's bad obviously we're always
talking about different kinds of fats
being good or bad and this documentary
really hits this home by criticizing a
lot of the research on the low-fat diet
let's take a look the rising tide of
heart disease and it comes from pretty
much out of nowhere to meet the nation's
leading cause of death in 1955 President
Eisenhower himself has a heart attack
and he's out of the Oval Office for 10
days the nation is fixated on this
problem an urgent public health problem
and nobody really knows what causes
heart disease right there's a number of
different explanations making lack of
vitamins maybe it's car exhaust so into
this vacuum steps Ancel keys a
pathologist from the University of
Minnesota and he says it's saturated
fats saturated fats and cholesterol
cause heart disease the document
criticizes the original research that
suggests that high-fat diets are linked
to heart disease they specifically are
calling out dr. Ansell keys who has
since been criticized and his research
has been called really selective and
biased and flawed several systematic
reviews nowadays have not been able to
show a clear association between total
dietary fat
and heart disease and this documentary
makes the claim that the low-fat diet
may actually do more harm than good
because when we take fat out of our diet
a lot of food manufacturers have to add
in a lot of sugar and salt to make up
for it so I definitely agree with them
on that part that's not necessarily a
great thing the other thing is a lot of
naturally high-fat foods are really
really good for you think about things
like avocado and nuts and seeds so so so
good so while I definitely advocate for
a little bit more balance where carbs
and fats can coexist I don't think that
going completely fat-free is really the
ideal claim number for the keto diet
Kuras diabetes so the documentary talks
a little bit about patient who's able to
completely get off insulin altogether
using the keto diet let's take a look
since the two months that I've been
doing this food program - it may just be
six weeks and within a month we were
able to decrease her insulin by half
even more I don't have anymore
sliding-scale regular short-acting I
have the long-term is down from 50 units
to 20 units a night so according to the
research a low to moderate carb diet may
help in the management of blood glucose
levels however we don't see the same
effect in the long term so it's safe to
say that the keto diet may help in the
management of type 2 diabetes however
whether it cures diabetes or whether it
can completely take you off of insulin
altogether has yet really to be seen in
the literature number 5 the keto diet
helps you lose weight so one of the big
reasons why people go on the keto diet
is of course to lose those big lbs and
the magic pill talks a lot about that so
let's meet one up there Weight Watchers
Debbie Debbie doesn't really look like
our Debbie but let's meet her anyway
since we started eating clean like this
so a lot of these people on the keto
diet do lose weight and this is
supported by the literature but for the
most part that's because you're eating
less and also because a lot of that
weight is water weight especially at the
very beginning the big question becomes
is this weight loss something that you
can actually maintain in the long term
so the research suggests that the
difference in weight loss between
someone on a really low carb diet like
the keto diet and another calorically
restrictive diet like a low-cal or low
fat diet is negligible at best by the
one-year mark and that's because
something like this is really hard for
people to maintain there's a high
dropout rate and even a lot of the
studies that they run so I always say
that the best diet you can do is the one
that you can do in the long term claim 6
the keto diet kills cancer let's take a
look at the documentary says with her to
application which is very aggressive and
metastatic type of breast cancer ok
so very much like the diabetes claim I
would say that this one is right and
kind of wrong so in this clip we're
talking about a woman who apparently was
able to cure her cancer by going on the
keto diet so the majority of studies in
this area are animal studies which does
not necessarily equate to humans so well
but a lot of the research has shown that
the keto diet may help with tumor
suppression or survival rates however we
definitely need a lot more research in
this area so it looks like the keto diet
may be an effective form of therapy
alongside other forms of treatment
however like diabetes I would never make
the claim that the keto diet is the cure
for all cancers or that you should just
stop all your other life-saving
treatments and just go eat high fat
foods so at the end of the day I think
that the magic pill makes some claims
that the keto diet that have some
research to back them up however a lot
of the times this research is really
it's maybe based on animal studies a lot
of case studies and anecdotal evidence
is included in here and sometimes it's
really really exaggerated so we don't
yet know a whole lot about the long-term
impacts or the magnitude of impacts and
while I agree with a lot of these
concepts here based on the early
research I think we've got a long way to
go before we can call the keto diets the
magic pill so guys I hope you enjoyed
this video you're gonna want to come
back next week where I discuss some of
the things that I think the documentary
got really wrong like not just
exaggerated but just flat-out wrong and
if you loved this video be sure to
subscribe to the channel leave me a
comment below with some of the things
that you think about the keto diet or
this documentary and I hope you guys
give it a big thumbs up and I will see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]